Let's exercise
in the definition of equivalent expressions.
Here I have an expression written in yellow,
and then I have two more, written with this pale green color.
I want you to pause the video and see if you can
to determine which of these expressions,
and it may not be any of them,
which one is equivalent to that in yellow.
I accept that experience.
I want to solve this task,
simplifying all as much as possible.
This one here is clear that it is not very simple.
Let's reveal the brackets.
If I multiply with the couple, what will happen?
This is equal to two by minus 6c, it is minus 12c.
Two plus three are plus six.
And then we have plus 4c.
Then we can simplify it further,
because I have these two articles that contain "c".
I have minus 12s plus 4c.
How much will it be?
Minus 12 of something plus four of something
it will be minus eight of this thing.
this will be equal to minus 8c.
If I gather these two members in blue,
I will get minus 8c.
And finally
plus six.
Now I see this is the same
as the first expression in green.
Therefore, this expression
will definitely be equivalent to yellow.
What about this one down here?
To understand, let's simplify it.
Let's reveal the brackets
Three in minus 4c is minus 12s.
Three in plus plus two is plus six.
Plus six and then we have plus plus 4c.
Looks good.
Now we can collect members that include "c".
Minus 12c and 4c, collect them together
and you get minus 8c.
Minus 8c plus six.
We got exactly the same as the other expressions.
Therefore, all these expressions
are equivalent.
This one, this and that.
Let's figure out another example.
And just like the last time, pause the video
and see which of these two expressions -
may be both or none of them,
or only one of them -
are equivalent
of this yellow expression?
Okay, let's do it together.
And as with the previous task, let us first simplify.
I first think of that
take the members that contain "n" and collect them.
Minus six of something in this case "n",
plus four of this thing, in this case "n".
Minus 6n plus 4n will give you
minus two of this thing.
Collect the odds.
Minus six plus four is minus 2n.
We have minus 2n and then plus minus 12,
which is the same as just minus 12.
So minus 12.
I simplified the original expression.
Let's see these down here.
If I uncover the braces,
I get four by "n", 4n.
And then four by minus three is minus 12.
And then we'll get 6n.
Yes, minus 6n.
What does this give us?
We get - let me use another color here - the following thing:
4n, I gather all members with "n",
minus 6n will give us 2n.
Then we have
minus 12.
By simplifying this expression, I get
same as the first expression.
So these two are equivalent.
This is equivalent to that.
Now let me check this one.
Two - let's just
I reveal the braces -
two by 2n is 4n.
Then two by minus 6 is minus 12.
This is simplified to 4n minus 12, and it is obvious that it is different
from minus 2n minus 12.
So this expression
is not the same as the other two.